League of Legends is in a strange place
on the one hand the lck is setting
viewership records on the other vlcs is
struggling but North America has a New
Hope a literal anime protagonist turned
Esports investor who's not afraid to
call things as he sees them now the LCS
and toast are teaming up in a new way
but can this strange Alliance bring back
the golden days of a forgotten era
thank you listen before we get into the
video let me tell you about another
video that also has a protagonist who
couldn't be stopped twists it's part of
our into the dark series presented by
Kraken rum and it explores the
sacrifices he made on his way to
becoming a major Champion that video is
already out so please go check it out
the link is in the description cheers so
now a decade out from the beginning of
the Western League of Legends leagues it
seems like North America has settled
into place and that place is
unfortunately the bottom maybe you'd
argue competitively the region has been
there for a while but the viewership
numbers are really starting to reflect
this reality too now with the LCS
pulling in record low numbers for summer
it really does feel like something needs
to change it's natural to compare the
situation to the lck where viewership
continues to Trend positively but let's
be honest what happened in crew Korea
with League of Legends isn't something
that is likely to happen everywhere and
on top of that the constant battle
between Genji and T1 is just incredibly
fun to watch it's obvious why the
viewership is doing well so maybe our
expectations for na league in 2023 need
to be adjusted but whence cometh
salvation disguised toast came from
Hearthstone conquered TFT joined offline
TV and on top of that has the highest
known IQ because of his time in Among Us
that's about all the background that I
can give you in this video but feel free
to check out our into the dark episode
on disguised host if you want to learn a
little bit more about where he came from
and his decision to become an Esports
team owner and it's been that Journey as
an owner that's been frankly the most
interesting and illustrative to me I was
always a fan of toast but seeing him
enter this space you know first with
valorent and then more recently with the
N.A CL team that he picked up in May has
been really cool and it's been that more
recent journey of becoming an Esports
team owner that I've found really
interesting and illustrative I've kind
of always been a fan of toast but seeing
him pick up first that valent roster and
then more recently the NaCl roster has
been interesting and frankly refreshing
maybe most refreshing of all is that he
hasn't shied away from criticizing
things along the way this week he was
pretty blunt with acerto in an interview
and said that the inability of the LCS
to create interesting story lines and
emotional investment was holding it back
now obviously pre-2017 the LCS had lots
of story lines and drama but they mostly
revolved around relegation and promotion
and at a certain point investors wanted
off of that wild ride I get why they
wanted it to end but there was something
undeniable about the drama of a
potential loss back then or the
Redemption of a player fighting their
way back to the LCS it still felt like
there was more on the line back then
because whether you were a pro player an
owner or just a fan success had to come
first and complete collapses had to be
avoided at any cost back then a team
could also theoretically fight their way
from being nobodies to the highest level
of competition so it had a sort of
romantic Allure as well your Friday
night stack really could theoretically
go all the way to the Top If Only your
co-worker Eric could figure out how to
use the push to talk button maybe you
say well that's just Nostalgia Josh and
I'm willing to accept that part of it
probably is more than that I think the
LCS and toast are two because Nostalgia
figures into their plans quite
prominently first off though I just want
to say that I think disguised brief
involvement so far and the NaCl has been
really positive from a competitive
standpoint it's been a success they
actually won summer more important than
any of that though is giving fans a
reason to care again a reason to get
excited and to come back to the league
week after week and it seems like that's
what toast wants to do now that the
recently announced na Legends
Invitational is an allusion to the
Golden Age of North American law toast
as the NaCl team owner and audience
stand-in will host the stream as Legends
of the game like aphromuscara sneaky and
Yasuo Captain teams of mixed na players
that's right each of the four squads in
this event will have an LCS player an
NaCl player and three streamers on top
of that we're getting the captain
flowers Azale team up so you know it's
going to be a crisp call again in the
press release toast points to wanting to
bring old and new fans together and I'm
not really sure how that will play out
the question of what the LC s should be
or should try to become is still
unanswered and while nothing is
impossible if you compare n a to the
other major regions they do seem pretty
inevitable right now even if we don't
have the precise answer though I'm happy
that someone like toast is finally
asking these questions and I'm also very
happy to see this Cooperative stance
from Riot even as toast criticizes
elements of their league still at the
end of the day we've got disguised an
NaCl team with players who would likely
play in the LCS but the team itself
remains trapped in challengers in that
same deserto interview toe said that he
wants a path to the LCS to be open to
him somehow but that he's also excited
to pump the stock on the tier 2 scene
the LCS remains a closed ecosystem that
has recently taken steps to cut costs I
haven't seen any indication that that'll
change anytime soon and toast is
drumming up interest in Na's tier 2
scene saying that he believes it can be
profitable but again how we get to that
point is unclear I do plan to watch the
na Legends Invitational broadcast and
hopefully bring a season 3 enjoyer or
two along for the ride but I don't know
where this is gonna go from here we're
living through an eventful time for
these leagues the OverWatch league is
set to unveil structural changes to
their league at Grand finals later this
year while valve came out and stated
that they're not happy about the closing
off of counter-strike's ecosystem and
that they expect changes to be put into
place for CS2 but unlike the OverWatch
League where a report from Jacob Wolfe
claimed that teams had approached the
league itself asking for a reprieve we
haven't seen that level of organization
at least in public in the LCS the team
owners were able to get the requirement
for Challengers teams dropped to help
save costs but as you may remember that
kicked off that hole labor dispute thing
there were also reports at the time that
some of these teams were aggressively
seeking Replacements but none of that
became necessary as the Players
Association and the league were able to
sort things out okay so here's the
bottom line if I were a team owner I'd
want disguised in the league the
question is how that can even happen
because right now the LCS is closed off
the teams that are there paid a bunch of
money to be there and at least for right
now for disguised they currently can't
[Music]